being swimmin Honan hey sign them there
have been a lot of memorable Disney
animals but you two are definitely some
of the most iconic ones anytime anyone
mentions Siamese cats you're the first
pets that come to mind you may not have
been the nicest characters but that song
was super catchy we are glad that you'll
be in the new version of Lady and the
[ __ ]
Disney is releasing a live-action remake
of the best dog love story ever we have
all the details about the new lady in
the [ __ ] keep watching to find out
which character has undergone a huge
transformation every day could be an
adventure trans inspiration passport
issues you'll need them the new [ __ ] is
played by a real dog named Monta but
Monty isn't your typical Hollywood dog
star he was found at an animal rescue in
Phoenix Arizona he had been transferred
from a shelter Monty is super sweet and
outgoing he's well behaved and loves
people and now he has a whole studio of
people who love him he's the perfect
[ __ ] [ __ ] is voiced by the actor
justin theroux in the new movie
spaghetti smooch is there any disease
seen more iconic than lady in the tramps
first kiss they get a plate of spaghetti
and share a long noodle and toad forces
them to kiss this scene has been
referenced and recreated countless of
times it just wouldn't be lady in the
[ __ ] without it but don't worry
Disney has promised that they will keep
the special spaghetti scene we haven't
seen it go down yet but it will be in
the final cut get your spaghetti ready
for the premiere the new lady we don't
know much about the dog that has
inspired lady but here's what we do know
she's a cocker spaniel just like the
original but she has brown and white
coloring instead of the typical sable
she is super adorable we also know that
she's being voiced by none other than
Tessa Thompson Tessa's taking a break
from filming for love and thunder for
Lady and the [ __ ] we can't wait to see
the new lady in action trusty The Hound
in lady in the [ __ ] lady has a couple
of good friends that are her neighbors
trusty is an old
pound and he is back in the new movie
ladies he is voiced by Sam Elliot and we
can't think of a better actor he has a
perfect voice for this wise gruff hound
dog he is suspicious of [ __ ] but
eventually he comes around in the
original trusty gets in an accident and
breaks his leg we don't know yet if that
will happen to the new trustee but if it
does thank goodness for CGI we are
Siamese we are Tsai amis if you please
the most recognized Disney cats are back
in the new film sy and em are the prissy
mean cats that belong to Aunt Sarah they
come to stay with lady in the new baby
and they cause a lot of trouble for lady
the original version came out in 1955
and the way sy and em were portrayed was
super offensive to people of Asian
descent thankfully Disney has gotten rid
of the bigoted undertones now they are
just cats who are really big
troublemakers finding the plot from what
we know so far the plot of lady in the
[ __ ] remake is really close to the
original it takes place in the early
1900s lady is the center of her people's
world until they have a baby they go
away for a while and then Sarah brings
her cats to stay with Lady and the baby
when she tries to muzzle ladies the dog
runs away and meets up with [ __ ]
they have adventures and to fall in love
and they live happily ever after
the gang's all here sheriff runs around
the streets with a couple of other dogs
they steal food and have adventures and
they're back in the new film and the
original tag is a pickin ease and bull
is a bulldog we don't know if their
breed are the same then of X Wong is
voicing bull which should make him one
funny pop and Janelle Monae is voicing
PEG we can't wait to see this gang of
street dogs in action the humans Lady
and the [ __ ] might be a movie about
dogs but there are several humans that
are important to the plot ladies owners
are Jim and darling dear Jim it's played
by American actor Thomas Mann Charlene
is played by the talented Kiersey
Clemons and of course we can't have sy
and em without Aunt Sarah she is played
by a vet in the cult Brown the evac'd is
no stranger to Disney as she is voiced
Luna on Elena of avalor release deets we
are so pumped about the new lady in the
[ __ ] we wish it was already out but
here's when you can expect to see it
lady in the [ __ ] dropped
on November 12 2019 however it won't be
in theaters Disney is releasing it on
their new streaming service Disney Plus
it will be available at the de Disney
Plus launches we wonder if we'll be
getting any other movies released
straight to streaming it's an exciting
time for Disney remakes Doc's new vibe
most of the characters in the
live-action Lady and the [ __ ] are
pretty much the same as their original
counterparts but one dog has changed you
might remember jock as the grumpy
Scottish terrier who lives near lady
that's a grand sight in the new version
jock is now a girl Scottie named Jackie
she is voiced by ashley Jensen are you
excited to watch the lady in the [ __ ]
remake what movies do you want to see
remade let us know in the comments
thanks for watching click that subscribe
button for more great videos from the
things and don't forget to give this one
a big thumbs up we'll see you next time
[Music]